prémices qui sortent de l'action avec
moins de sièges
d'un autre côté des messieurs pourquoi
un lieu sûr répétait-il qu'un premier
ministre sortant qui voit son parti
terminé deuxième
le soir des élections doit céder son
poste ça semble une évidence c'est parce
que ce n'est pas automatique en
situation de gouvernement minoritaire
[Musique]
donc lundi soir les libéraux arrivent
deuxièmes avec moins de sièges que les
conservateurs
mais que les troupes de gauchir
n'obtienne pas de majorité
savez vous que justin trudeau pourrait
refuser de concéder la victoire ce sud
est question pour des académiques c'est
des questions pour des experts
on va regarder ça cela suivre en cas
d'égalité ou avec moins de députés qu'un
autre parti le premier ministre sortant
dispose d'un avantage si le parti qui
arrive premier n'a pas la majorité le
premier ministre sortant peut tenter de
rallier d'autres députés et continuer à
gouverner
donc même en terminant 2e justin trudeau
pourrait tenter de rallier des députés
du npd ou des verts convaincre ceux du
bloc serait sans doute impossible
je voudrais pas dans une coalition jade
répond un parti politique
si lors du discours du trône le chef
libéral obtient l'appui d'une majorité
de députés en chambre et y est ils
pourraient continuer à gouverner
ce scénario est hautement improbable il
ya eu une douzaine de gouvernement
minoritaire d'avoir une seule fois le
parti est arrivé deuxième a décidé de
conserver le pouvoir
en 1925 les libéraux de mackenzie king
ont terminé deuxième avec 15 sièges de
moins que les conservateurs mais les
troupes conservatrices n'ont pas obtenu
de majorité en tant que premier ministre
sortant mais kenzy king a pu demeurer en
poste avec l'appui des progressistes
bon